it was a romantic idea from the start
the journey became something that we we
could never have planned was all love it
really was yes yeah everybody got there
was no legal whatsoever on that dream we
were lucky enough to work with real
candy people and so they made the dream
sort of country which is which was
really amazed we all got to kind of go
back in time a little and and just roll
through a part of the world that felt
like we were on our own kind of mystical
journey the metaphor to me is the
history of trains and and an Old West
movies where trains are represent
freedom and adventure in the frontier
like people were jumping on instruments
that they were not very well-versed at
some guy just jumped on the train that
wasn't even supposed to be there and
played tambourine all night long with
these guys and everyone would be
laughing and jumping around and
supporting it and that was so great to
see like you know just sort of bad music
being played and everyone loving it yeah
like that was so good yeah and then
during the live sets it was that way the
night ended with the biggest testament
of that vibe is that it really was
everybody kind of playing together and
rolling in and out of each other sets
and once you're in that state of mind
everything's easy you know the music the
good times all of that just comes kind
of right out and I think that was
probably summed up everything for us
it's silly to think that that something
physical like something made by man like
you can get in this thing and travel and
suddenly you feel like you're in a
magical situation but it's it's it's
just absolutely true
magic
you